ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวยดีค่ะนักเรียนฟ้าวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันนี้ต่อมันจันทร์นี้วันจันทร์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 20 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีคศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
World วันนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้าเมื่อวานนี้
วัน
ข้อคิดวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 19 เดือน
เดือนมิถุนายนปีพตตเส้น
[เพลง]
ปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีพตอะไรคะปีคศ
022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
21 เดือน
เดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตตปีพต 2  565
เอคอศ.ปีคปี
2022 ค่ะค่ะ
ฟ้าตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
10:00 น 10 โมงกี่นาที
สิบโมง 41 นาทีค่ะ 10 โมง 41 นาทีก็เป็น
ตอนกลางวันกลางวันผู้หญิงอยู่ที่บ้าน
อีกเหลืองนี้ใช่ค่ะครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ทำงาน
ทำงานอยู่ที่บ้านเงินดาวน์ 2 คนเนี่ยก็ก็
มีคู่ความที่เราผู้หญิงว่าอะไรคะ
Notebook ค่ะใช่
มีเม้าส์เห็นไหมเราสองคนเนี่ยก็
ผลงานจากที่บ้านใช่ไหมทำผ่านคอมพิวเตอร์
ครูอู๋ฟ้าพระเราสองคนเนี่ยทำงานอะไร
เราสองคนนะคะคือฟ้ากับครูหญิงทำงานเป็น
ครู
ตายครูสอนอะไรคะ
ครูสอนภาษาไทยค่ะ
สอนภาษาไทยครูฟ้า
ถ้า
เอาบ้านเข้าไปนะคะวันนี้กูฟ้ามีผมมาใช่
ไหมแล้วก็โทรฟ้ามัดผมอยู่มีแว่นตาใหญ่ๆ
ชายลูกค้าเนี่ยคิดว่า
เราสองคนน้องเราสองคนทำงานเป็นครูความคิด
ว่างานอะไรนะเป็นครูเนี่ย
เราทำงานเป็นครูเนี่ยเป็นครูมีอันตรายไหม
ลูกฟ้ากับครูหญิง
ทำงานเป็นครู
ไม่อันตรายคะ
คือฟ้า
ทำไมทำไมครูฟ้าคิดว่าไม่อันตราย
รู้ป๊าคิดว่าทำงานเป็นครูโอเคครูก็สอน
สอนภาษาไทยใช่มั้ยนักเรียนก็โอเคนักเรียน
ไม่โกรธใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้ากับคุณหญิงสอนภาษา
ไทยนักเรียนไม่โกรธนักเรียนโอเค
เมื่อกี้นี้กูหญิงเห็นครูฟ้าค้างนะก็เลย
ว่าอินเตอร์เน็ตผู้หญิงโอเคไหมใช่ไม่
อันตรายเนาะไม่ไม่ตายง่ายๆเป็นไงไม่ต้อง
มีอันนี้ใช่ไหมหรือ
เปล่าว่าอะไร
ปืน
อ๋อใช่ไซส์เลอ
[เพลง]
ผู้จัดปายยฟ้าคิดอะไร
ครูฟาคิดว่า fbi
ตรวจงานตำรวจอันตราย
ทำไมอ่ะ
เอ้าตำรวจเนี่ยต้องวิ่ง
วิ่งวิ่ง
แล้วก็ไปจับตำรวจจับคนร้ายนะฮะฝุ่นไม่มี
อะหรอคนไม่ดีคนไม่ดีก็มีตื่นใช่ไหม
ตื่นหมอกก็ยิงตำรวจตายได้ใช้หายิงตำรวจๆ
อายได้ค่ะผู้หญิงกูพายก็เลยคิดว่า
ตำรวจจะให้พี่อันนี้เป็นตำรวจล่ะคิดดีๆนะ
ตำรวจเนี่ยน่าจะเป็นงานที่อันตราย
อัน
น่ากลัวและมี
เปอร์เซ็นต์มากๆที่สดับตาไม่ไม่ตายตายแต่
ครีเอมีอะไรมีแค่
0.01 อาจจะมีแค่ประมาณ
[เพลง]
1% ที่ตายครูเนาะครูก็เลยเป็นงานที่ไม่
อันตรายแต่ตำรวจเนี่ยอาจจะมีโอาสมีประมาณ
80% กับเออตายได้ก็อันตรายทั้งนี้หากผู้
หญิงแล้วผู้หญิงคิดว่ามีงานอะไรที่
อันตรายไหมคะ
มีค่ะขลุ่ยคิดว่างานนี้เนี่ยอันตรายดีมาก
ๆ
อะไหล่ทั้งผู้หญิงงานที่อันตรายมากๆนะดับ
เพลิงแค่แหละพนักงานดับเพลิงไหมนักดับ
เพลิงนั่นแหละ
เลิงใช่ไหมนักดับเพลิงก็คือเขาก็จะมีรถ
มีรถหรอรถเค้าจะเป็นยังไงนะ
รถใหญ่ไหมใหญ่ค่ะอันนี้ก็จะมีสายใช่ไหมมี
สายอันนี้ก็จะมีคนค่ะ
ก็จะ
วอ
สูบตัดเสียงนะคะ
เปลี่ยนในรถก็จะมีคนใช่ไหมอ่ะตรงนี้ก็จะ
มีคนด้วยนะคะนี่แหละคนนี้แหละเราเรียกว่า
นัดดับเพลิงนัดดำเลยเนี่ยเวลาที่เขาทำงาน
แล้วคือถ้ามีตึกมี
ผมชื่อทำไมแล้วก็มีไฟไหม้มามีไฟไหม้เวลา
มีไฟไหม้เนี่ยเราก็จะโทรประเทศไทยเนี่ย
199 นะคะประเทศไทยโทรฮัลโหลตอนนี้ที่
อพาร์ตเมนต์ A มีไฟไม่ให้อะไรกับจอยค่ะไฟ
นะคะคุณฟ้าผู้หญิงนะเหมือนหญ้า
สีส้มสีส้มได้อยู่โอเค
ไฟไหม้อ่านักเรียน
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเสียใจๆก็ได้แค่นี้พอไหมพอ
ทำผู้หญิงสวยงามมากกว่าเดิม
นัดดับเพลิงเนี่ยเขาจะขับรถ
วอแล้วก็ขับมาแล้วก็จะมี
สายใช่ไหมแล้วก็จะฉีดน้ำอาเภอแต่บางครั้ง
เนี่ยในอพาร์ตเมนต์ในคอนโดมิเนียมและมีคน
ขนใช่ไหมคะนัทเด้ะเลยเขาก็ต้องออกมาแล้ว
ก็วิ่ง
หน้านั้นเบอร์ไหนก็ต้องเข้าเข้าเข้าไป
ข้างในแล้วก็ 1 ช่วยคนออกมาก็มี
เปอร์เซ็นอาจจะ
90% ที่จะตายได้ผู้หญิงก็เลยคิดว่าคนที่
ทำงานเป็นนักดับเพลิง
อย่างเนี้ยอันตรายมากๆ
น่าสนใจหาใช่ผู้หญิงอันตราย
เพราะว่าน่ากลัว does หน้า
ถ้าเมื่อก่อนช่วยไหมมึงก้อนมาก่อนปีอะไร
อ่ะ
อีกทีปี
ฟ้าเกิดเขาไม่เอาเบอร์เทรดเซ็นเตอร์ฟ้า
รู้จัก world  trade  center ไหมที่จะ
เป็นคือไม่ยิงใส่เป็นตึก 2 ตื่นก็เรียก
ตึกแสนอ่ะเราก็มีเรื่องดีหรือคุยขอโทษนะ
คะถ้านักเรียนบางคนแบบที่อาจจะมีลิกเกอร์
warning นิดหน่อยนะวิ่งชนใช่ไหมแล้วก็
ตึกเนี่ยถล่มลงมาแล้วใกล้ๆเวอเทรดก็มี
สถานีดับเพลิงแล้วก็มีนัดดับเลิงเนี่ยผู้
ชายแล้วก็วิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งเข้าไปช่วยคน
ไหมมีหลายๆคนเนี่ยที่ตายผู้หญิงก็เลยคิด
หูทำงานเป็นนักดับเพลิง
อันตรายมากๆ
ใช่หอกผู้หญิงเพราะว่าเข้าไปแล้วไฟไม่ใช่
ไหมไฟไหม้เองมากเลยอ่ะพอดีเบอร์เซ็นใช่
ไหมที่จะตายมากๆใช้ฮะนอกจากรักดับเพลิง
ครูคิดว่าอันนี้นะครูฟ้ายังคิดว่ามีงาน
ที่อันตรายอีกหรอมีหากรูหญิงมีหากู้ไฟล์
คิดว่า
ขย้ำกัน
งานอะไรคะครูฟ้า
อันนี้ขนาดคนเหรอคะ
ไม่รู้หรือยังคะอะไร
นะ
แว่นขยายใช่ไหมอันเนี้ย
[เพลง]
อันนี้นะอันนี้คือแว่นขยาย
นัดสืบเหรอคะครูฟ้า
ให้กับผู้หญิงก็หญิงเก่งมากเลยค่ะผู้หญิง
รู้ได้ยังไงเนี่ย
นักสืบคะ
นักสืบค่ะครูหญิง
ทำไมครูฟ้าคิดว่านักสืบเป็นงานที่อันตราย
เหล่านักสืบเนี่ยใช่ไหมกูไฟเมื่อไหร่แล้ว
อ้าเต็ดนะ
รอฟังเพลงครูฟ้าคิดว่านัดสื่อเป็นงานที่
อันตราย
เพราะว่านักสืบเนี่ย
นักสืบแล้วครูหญิงต้องสื่อพี่ไหมถ้าเกิด
มีคน
คนที่คนไทย
คนไม่ดีใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะอ่ะ
มี
คนยิงกันทั้งๆฟังต้องยิงกันแล้วคนนี้ก็
ตาย
แล้วคนนี้ก็
หนีไม่บายได้เรื่อยๆหนีหนีหน้าหมีมีนัก
สืบเนี่ยใช่มั้ยนักสืบก็ต้องหาใครเป็นคน
ยิง
และถ้านักสืบหาใช่ไหมหาใครเป็นคนยิงก็อาจ
จะมีคนร้าย
คิดค่านักสืบไม่ให้นักสืบหาเจอ
ชัยหยิ่ง
ช่วยหายิงตั้งแป้ง
ครูฟ้าคุณครูหญิงคิดว่านะนะคนที่ทำงานนัก
สืบอันตรายแล้วก็ถ้านักสืบแต่งงานเนี่ยมี
ภรรยามีลูก
ภรรยาลูกก็อันตรายเหมือนกันนะ
ทำไมอ่ะผู้หญิงก็คนไม่ใช่นี้นักสืบอันนี้
ใช่ไหมอ่ะคนร้ายคนไม่ดีเนี่ยก็อาจจะจับ
ภรรยาหรือว่าลูกนักสืบแล้วก็บอกนักสืบ
ห้ามหาว่าใครทำก็อันตาลายเหมือนกันใหม่งู
นักสืบอันตรายนะชื่อล็อคโฮล์มส์ใช่มั้ย
นักสืบสายค่ะหรือว่านักสืบบางทีประเทศนัก
เรียนตำรวจได้มั้ยตำรวจก็เป็นนักสืบคู่
ม้าผู้หญิงคิดว่ามีงานอีกหนึ่งงานที่
อันตราย
อะไรคะผู้หญิงเออกูฝาก็ชอบเป็นตำรวจใช่
ไหมกับปืนให้ชอบคอนโดอพาร์ทเม้นท์ค่ะ
วิ่งจะพูดอะไรคะเอ้าครูฟ้านี่ไง
อพาร์ทเม้นท์หรือว่าคอนโดมิเนียมเนี่ยอ่ะ
สูงเทสซูมมากๆอาจจะให้มากกว่า 10 เมตรนี้
ไม่ใช่สิ่งมันน่ะ 50 เมตรมันแต่ว่าทุกๆ
วันเนี่ยฝนตก
หรือว่ามีอะขับรถใช่ไหมก็จะมีฝุ่นฝุ่น
เกาะอ่ะอพาร์ทเม้นท์หรือว่าตึกเนี่ยก็ไม่
สะอาดทำไมส่งมันก็จะมี
คน
คนที่
ที่อยู่ที่เนี่ยที่นั่งอยู่ที่นี่ใช่ไหม
คะแล้วก็อาจจะเป็นผู้ชายแล้วมาทำความ
สะอาด
ทำความสะอาดจะเช็ดกระจกที่ตึกสมัยที่ตึก
ที่อพาร์ตเมนต์เนี่ยบางทีมันไม่สะอาด S
ใช่มั้ยเช็ดเนี่ยคนเนี้ยคนที่ทำความสะอาด
ตึก
สูงๆควีนคิดว่าเป็นงานที่อันตรายอาจจะมี
เปอร์เซ็นต์ที่แบบตกลง Bar แล้วก็ตายได้
ใช่ผู้หญิงตกลงมาตายได้เหรอนี้เพราะเห็น
เออบ่อยๆใช่ไหมอันนี้ก็รู้ว่าผู้หญิงกู
ฟ้าทำไหม
ถ้าได้เงินสัก 1 ล้านกูฟ้าทำนะผู้หญิงใบ
อ่ะผู้หญิงกรองความสูงนาคผู้หญิงนั่งอยู่
ที่ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าแล้วก็มองมองลงไก่เออไม่
อ่าโอเคผู้หญิงกับผู้หญิงจะได้เงินหนึ่ง
ล้านอ่ะ
1 ล้านใช่ไหมภูฟ้า 1 ล้านบาทใช้อะไรแว็ป
ไม่เอาหรอไม่โอเคโอเคค่ะมันซูร์มากๆเลยนะ
ภูฟ้า
ไงแต่เงินเยอะล่ะใช่ค่ะงานอันตราย
ใช่ไหมเน็ตประจบฝึกหรือว่า Apartment
Condominium สูงๆเนี่ยเราต้องเช็ดกระจก
มันเป็นงานที่อันตราย
meomee เปอร์เซ็นต์ที่จะตายมากๆก็ต้อง
ได้เงินเยอะๆ
ถูกต้องค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมันเป็นงานที่
นั่งรู้ว่าจ่ายแต่ประเทศไทยได้เงินนิด
หน่อยนะคะไม่ว่าจะเป็น
คนเช็ดกระจกหรือนัดดับเพลิงสมัยก็จะมีไฟ
ไหม้แล้วก็
ฉีดน้ำแน่นักดับเพลิงก็ไปได้ไทยคิดว่า
เงินนิดหน่อยไม่เยอะมากนะแต่ไม่มีงานที่
ทำเนี่ยอันตรายมากๆนะคะนี่ใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้า
กับครูหญิงเนี่ยก็คิดว่าน้องมีงานที่เป็น
ครูบาคิดมีตำรวจสมัย fbi นักซื้อ
แต่เป็นงานที่อันตรายครูหญิงก็คิดนัดดับ
เพลิง
แล้วก็คนเช็ดกระจกตึกสูงสุดคุ้มสมัยเป็น
งานที่อันตรายนะคะใช่หานักเรียนแล้วนัก
เรียนคิดว่างานอะไรที่อันตราย
ที่ว่าน่ากลัวต้องคอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้เนาะ
แต่วีดีโอดี๊ว่าหมดเวลาแรงแล้วไหมอ่ะอา
นานักเรียนก็นักเรียนแล้วเดี๋ยวเราก็มา
เจอกันใหม่มี vdo หน้านานักเรียนขอให้นัก
เรียนดูแลตัวเองนะคะแข็งแรงใจแล้วแล้วเจอ
กันค่ะสวัสดีช่องวันที่หา